hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome to episode 38 of game
programming so yesterday I keep saying
that as if this show is daily last
episode is what I mean you guys know
that last episode we took a look at this
friggin void tile thing well not really
this void tell thing but there's this
problem here solving that arraigned X
out of balance exception where if we go
out of bounds of map we'll just simply
return a void tile that's what we did
last time and today we want to take a
look at fixing this procedural
generation problem best it's not really
procedural generation why like
procedural rendering but you can see
that every time we move we get these
black bars basically and it just does
not look very good now what this is
though is it's like I don't know I
really like this I really do because it
shows very clearly how how this thing is
rendering because you can see that
basically as soon as we access a tile
further down here is cutting out a tile
here so we're not actually rendering the
entire map at once we're just rendering
what we see in this little window which
is beautiful because you can see wearing
a fruit and 4,000 frames per second and
that's just freakin insane so um that's
that's brilliant
then again I do have a supercomputer so
you guys probably weren't burning that
fast but the point is we're still
running extremely fast which is awesome
so now we need it where to fix this
because like from a technical standpoint
this looks freaking amazing but from an
aesthetical standpoint no not really
so we thought I want to fix that up and
make this really smooth now there are a
few things we do to actually achieve
that first of all you'll see that we've
actually got three areas of black bonus
it's not happening to the vertical it's
not happening to this this edge of the
screen the top edge of the screen not as
I'm sure why but it was just not so
let's just roll with that but yes I'm
happening to the top so we don't even do
anything about now that's beautiful
it is happening to the bottom the left
and you right so yeah
let's think about that so first of all
the first thing you need to consider is
what is happening with each edge now the
two of these edges have something in
common and that is the bottom one and
the right one and the reason they have
something in common the thing that they
have in common here is the fact that
they are actually like the exceeding
like things right so in other words
because remember zero is zero the
coordinate zero zero is in the top
left corner in our game all right which
means that this is the far right and
this is like the far bottom corner this
is like zero that the top and left
they're both zero but the right one is
width and the bottom one is height that
is what those edges are equal to and so
to deal with them we'll clearly need to
do something about height and width
respectively to actually you know fix
this fix the right and the bottom
corners edges rather but for the left
side we actually have to do something
with well with zero or basically we need
to do something with zero now it is our
currently set to zero but you can see
the zero just is not low enough and we
actually have to go a bit lower we need
to go deeper but we need to go a bit
lower to actually fix this thing so how
we're going to do that so let's let's
talk about fixing the left side for a
minute so to fix that we'll go into our
screen Java class and right over here in
render tile that's where all the magic
happens so at the moment you can see
that we're actually breaking right we're
breaking when X a is less than zero and
our X is obviously the problematic zone
here because X is our horizontal and
that's where our problem is on the left
side it's when it's less than zero it's
breaking now zero does not seem to be
low enough so yeah it looks like it's
actually offset by an entire tile if we
go over here that's basically the size
of a tile right it is if you freaking
draw that there that's pretty much the
size of a tile it might be like two
pixels less but point is we'll just
assume that's the size the size of the
tile especially to be safe anyway so to
fix that let's just simply you know set
it to minus one tile that way so minus
one tile left so basically we can just
set it to minus 16 but again to fish
Brutus thing we can set it to minus
tales sprite size because tell describe
tile size is 16 remember in this case
and we'll just you know basically
multiply by negative 1 to make it
negative 16 and that is it if we
actually run this now first of all if we
were on this you'll see that we crash
and the reason we crash obviously is
actually you know what let's debug this
for you guys you can see we've crashed
here because XP value is negative 15
so it's obviously going to be an array
index out of bounds exception because
pixels the index of pixels that is
trying to look up is actually returning
a negative number you can see right here
it's negative 15 that's a problem so you
want to fix that we simply need to say
all right well don't break in that case
if it's negative if he goes into the
negative don't necessarily break let's
first of all because what remember what
it's doing is it it's it's it's only
breaking when it's less than negative 16
but what if it's negative 10 for example
you know that's that's gonna that's kind
of passed through this it's not going to
break in that case but what it is going
to do is throw throw an array index out
of bounds exception so what we'll say is
all right well if it is negative 10 for
example don't don't really break right
because we've said it not to break which
is good because before it did break
let's not break but let's just let's
just set it to zero so if X a is less
than zero let's just set X a equal to
zero and what that will do is actually
say that if it's less than zero well
it's just going to make it equal zero
and as you can see that fixes our
problem now our left side is beautiful
no no what you guys are thinking you
guys thinking oh that was easy let's do
the same thing to X to this and we'll
just you know we'll just we'll just add
on 16 to both width and height and
that'll be fun
no it won't be fine you can't do that
can't do it for that all right well we
can do however is going to our level
class and actually expand this rendering
zone we can't actually do it for this is
actually kind of a kind of like a
phenomenon something for some reason we
can't actually do the negative stuff to
X to the to the to the lower corner
pencil X 0 and y 0 but we we can sort of
expand the x1 and y1 so it's it's been
interesting but the thing is at the
moment we're looking up SQL plus screen
width which gives us one basically one
full like tile thing right you can see
that's exactly like one full one full
tile thing but then we sort of cross
over here alright and you can see that
it's sort of offset it's out by one tile
again for both sides so what we can do
is simply add on the size of one time
so literally just add on sixteen till
the end and again what that is going to
do is it's going to get the X : y scroll
values and it's going to add on the
width and then it's going to add on a
further 16 just just to be one tile safe
so it's going to just render one more
tile and that all sort of prevent that
screen thing now what we've got here you
can see is a perfectly running thing and
because we're still running a pretty
much the same frame rate this screen
recorder sort of mocks things up a bit
but you can see that we're running about
3700 frames per second and and that's
great so we fixed it with mineral salt
performance impact again of course there
will be a very very slight performance
impact because we are actually rendering
one one more tile horizontally and
vertically and the other way
horizontally as well but you know that
that's the price we pay to make a game
look good nice one last thing I'll
mention quickly is yeah we've got this
issue here where it's 16 and it's not
tile it's not actually the size of the
tile there's several ways we're going to
fix that so in other words you can see
that over here in our screen class we
actually managed to go to a loss by the
size which we can't do here um in our
level thing but that's alright we'll fix
that later on when we actually you know
change this this time I third a bit but
yeah so anyway that's what we get that's
what we get our beautiful result of the
game which now looks really nice
basically looks freaking amazing it's
ready to freaking put and put a
pre-alpha version up on a website and
get people downloaded because it's it's
pretty damn good
but yeah that is the end of this episode
I hope you enjoyed this episode if you
did please hit that like button give
this video favorite because it was
freaking amazing and I will see you guys
next time goodbye
you